well what an interesting month to have a
newborn to say the least now I was
planning on taking about a month off for
paternity leave and that started about a
week before the whole self quarantine
thing so it's kind of good to see
everyone joining in in the spirit things
are going well over here what is it it's
1:30 in the morning and my night shift
has begun oh sorry
I totally forgot the introductions meet
little baby Gwen the latest addition to
the quorum family she's doing well
what do you do with all your time at
home well that was a question that I had
already figured out about a week before
the self quarantine started each gives
handful so whenever I'm not trying to
catch a few extra hours of sleep I'm in
here and our little home office plugging
away and a couple new exciting things
that I'm really really really amped
about I have been finishing a new album
that's going to be coming out very
shortly
and playing this 8-string guitar as well
recently but something a little more
relevant to what you guys see on this
channel is I've been learning unity and
unreal on a much deeper level not
necessarily for game development but for
virtual production development now if
you saw in that visual effects artists
react episode about blue Mandalorian
you're all really really excited about
some of the techniques they used to
capture life on stage in this scene all
of the background you're seeing is not
real it is a real-time rendered image on
a LED screen so inspiring that look
literally right now I'm working on a
mini version of this that will be able
to have in our own studio so on the
unity side of things we're working with
Josh Davies over FX home to develop a
camera calibration plugin that allows us
to use real-world photos just like you
see here and basically have a real-time
rendered environment that's free tracked
to this camera and that's gonna be
really cool it's very similar to this
setup they used on the Mandalorian on
the unreal side of things I am just
diving right in while I'm not as
familiar with unreal it is it is so
powerful it is so cool and easy to learn
and so I've really been enjoying messing
around with that why would you want to
turn to like a video game engine to
start making videos with it's a good
question because you know you might
think oh well there's kind of a drop in
quality and since the rendering isn't as
high quality but the thing is is there's
this level of unprecedented freedom that
is very very alluring because normally
work making visual effects and putting
them into a live footage but right now
this is a situation what we're gonna be
taking live footage and putting it into
a visual effects so to speak or act the
whole shot it's gonna be CG you know if
we really want to set it up right we can
do a thing where you knew your actor
mocap suit you have a CG environment you
maybe have like a buy of track camera or
a virtual camera trick it starts to
really mimic just a normal set at that
point where you're just recording takes
and if you want you can screen capture
your computer and the moment your take
is done you have footage now to edit
with because it's all real time yeah
it's it's a really cool situation and
it's really exciting now we have an
opportunity to tell stories that would
otherwise be completely impossible so
we're gonna be bringing all this virtual
production stuff to a video that we'll
be releasing soon on this channel don't
forget to say subscribe to them when
you're stuck at home it's always a good
opportunity to also reorganize be a
really really cool opportunity to
reorganize my workspace and I'm super
excited about it as I said I'm reporting
a lot of music so I've got a full music
set up here with my guitar rigs my
pedals my audio the cool feature that I
did here pull out keyboard so I can play
music at my desk and record it
the deluxe the set up but you know you
can do it for really cheap it's just
partying all the pieces together and if
you guys haven't seen it I highly
recommend building a slab PC on a wall
it is so cool it saves tons of space so
that's the update from Sam's house here
yeah I hope you guys are staying safe
out there
and you've learned something new if you
got a PC fired up learn some visual
effects learn the game engine rights
music make art do whatever you can to
keep yourself sharp can't wait to get
back to the studio and start turning
some of this stuff that I'm learning
into stuff that you guys get to see it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool guys baby
got anyone's K bye
through puddles through subscribe to the
choice
well Oh spit up I don't think I'm
getting by by her she sends her regards
hey guys I'm Matt and you might not know
me too well
but you've probably seen me get shot in
the Keanu Reeves deep fake and get shot
at in the Boston Dynamics video but what
I'm not getting shot at I work at this
here YouTube channel and so far I have
had a blast with these guys I love
coming to the studio every day now
obviously things are a little bit
different right now I'm working from
home the whole studio is now I want to
be able to bring the studio environment
and all of my friends back home with me
somehow there is one thing I haven't
told you and that is that I am also a
VFX artist see the the particles
I'm going to utilize my green-screen
blanket from corridor digital and we
actually just restocked these so if you
want one for yourself head on down the
corridor digital dot store now all I
have to do is throw this blanket up in
the background so let's go ahead and try
it out Wow great that was a visual
effects - okay here we go I'm just gonna
clap my hands and we will be transported
through chroma key technology whoa we're
back at the studio it's like we never
left oh hey let's do our secret VFX
handshake hey you know what I'm not
gonna be doing all this via flexing
without giving you guys the opportunity
to be wherever you want to be if you
have an emergency green-screen blanket
throw it up behind you and send me a
picture on the DMS on Instagram and I'll
put you wherever you want to be name a
place don't make it weird
also why are their follow up corridor
digital I'm the on the grim hey
everybody gather around because I got
some fresh edits for you guys to check
out
I drove red oh okay okay everybody stop
doing all the things that are happening
right now how are we supposed to get any
work done around here anyway
let's check this clip out guys no axes
what's up people welcome to the
quarantine zone which boy yes that's me
yo so quarantine booth that's got a
whiff of my own breath I'll be right
back
I keep getting challenges on the
Internet's push up challenges acrobatic
challenges and today I said you know
what I'm gonna do the most intricate
acrobatic challenge of them all so let's
go downstairs and try this challenge
alright alright so that's what kill oh
and this is the next order I got to do
that that so I don't actually know if I
could do any of that I'm gonna start at
the last part first okay okay I can I
can do that area
the ninjas dance to kid bug to turn
around push up to that dance move up
Arielle nudist dance area business kippa
pooja boom
hold up there was a turn around in there
kip-up turn around push up whoa whoa
that's a game changer kid all right
it's the aerial that's the hardest to
get over I think okay I was about to go
but something inside me was not feeling
it I'm feeling it now
well what's that feeling it's my
neighbor Vanessa guys let's see we can
zoom in our I'm the creepy
that's my creepy neighbor make sure I
could do this
I'm trying yeah let me see all right
[Music]
it might have been pretty but I did it
all right Vanessa thank you hey guys I
just wanted to say I hope you've been
enjoying these little vlogs we've been
doing recently they've been a ton of fun
and it's been fun to do with something a
little bit different here on the
corridor crew Channel we get a lot of
questions all the time about filming and
about filming equipment and about what
to use and how to get started and I'd
like to answer that in our store
corridor digital dot store there is an
emergency green-screen blanket not only
will it keep you warm it comes at a very
affordable price and it's versatile you
can fold it up you can take it with you
you can pretty much go anywhere and do
anything with it
zoom meetings you can put it behind you
you know maybe get a nice isolated edge
put yourself wherever you want to be
maybe you're stuck at home but you want
to be in the Caribbean well guess what
the emergency green-screen blanket is
available now at corridor digital dot
store
[Music]